by an Ave car tester Emmanuel Schaefer
says car makers always come up with
something unusual to introduce a new
model Skoda has chosen an Art Museum in
Stockholm for the car rocks world
premiere the art apolog host exhibitions
and can be rented for events like this
Skoda premiere more than 350 journalists
from 29 countries travel to Stockholm to
meet the new car rock Skoda unveiled the
successor to the Yeti with plenty of
special effects and flare designers have
changed the cars look the boxiness of
the Yeti is so yesterday and with the
new lines came a new name the car rock
the word is derived from an indigenous
Alaskan language as is Kodiak and it's a
combination of the concepts Auto and
arrow
scooters head of development Christian
scuba says that they've reinvented the
Yeti from the ground up it has a new
platform based on Volkswagens MQB
toolkit that enables the two car makers
to collaborate on development the car
rack shares its technology with another
VW Group member the Sierra tikka both
roll off the assembly line at the same
time connectivity and safe smartphone
use and driving our key features for
many potential buyers school - CEO Ben
Hart Meyer says digital technology is
important today and Skoda wants to make
cars into a perfect 3rd place after home
and office we want drivers to have the
same opportunities to communicate that
they have in those places
thanks to Skoda connect the vehicle is
always linked to the Internet
that way it can provide not just
entertainment but also information and
support suggesting alternative routes
for example or automatically making
emergency calls full LED headlights with
integrated day running lights are
available as an option the running
lights also double as indicators the
engines haven't changed much they've
already made appearances in a range of
VW models and can deliver between 85 and
140 kilowatts of power to petrol engines
and three diesel will be available to
start kenobi length manual says the car
rack is much roomier than it looks with
the seats folded down more than 1500
liters of space are available and with
the variable loading system you can haul
cargo of all sizes and shapes what's
called the Vario flex system is composed
of three individual rear seats that can
be positioned separately or taken out
entirely that gives the car rack a
maximum cargo space of 1810 liters the
new Skoda car rack will show up in
dealer showrooms in autumn of this year
prices haven't been set yet but it's
estimated a basic model will sell for
about 21 thousand euros
you
[Music]